today's topic I don't wanna know you
know it's gonna be good
do you think it's good to be like
forthright about what you're looking for
absolutely why waste your time with this
like well maybe like he'll change or
it'll work cuz if he's a Scorpio and you
don't want to Scorpio it's like why
waste your time get a Libra like oh my
god libras are I mean
Capricorn's are fine too
[Applause]
[Music]
so like you're drinking a big-ass Dookie
let's go let's do this yo why am i dizzy
I got a low blood pressure
I think I'm not well bro alright here we
go I can't do it hey photo bomber no hmm
raining you guys made me go from
yesterday we'll just do it oh I just
want to show up to a sexual experience
the girls taking off my pants ah these
are my underwears from last week
all right Annie who doesn't want to go
on a date with Angie
three two one soon as she said the
Scorpio stuff I would have walked out
immediately
like if you're Scorpio like I'm not even
into astrology either no no no no okay
no
you can't be saying I'm not aiming in
the astrology and then X people upon
astrology okay no I don't even really
believe in religion but if you don't
believe in my god we can't date Nam
peace you know was the white version of
you got me [ __ ] up hmm
newsflash this person is definitely
gonna end up either alone at the end of
this or would like one person at most
there's no way there's just no way
someone this detestable is going to get
so I definitely do need a date somebody
who's like down for vegan food once in a
while all the time mostly vegan
[Music]
doughnuts are vegan too horoscopes and
then veganism like I'll dip now this is
like two strikes I'm not gonna wait till
the third one to be disappointed I'm
different
that's what it was freaky freaky
guarantee anybody who does this amount
of dumb stuff talking about horoscopes
and all that she doesn't know I know
that I mean I really do appreciate
adventurous just because I meant
obviously an adventurous person if
someone's down to us from the part I'm
like all about it anal congratulations
they got chlamydia or or nine apart cuz
there's kids there okay let's see sting
that's nasty sting is not nice like I
don't think she's ever done because if
you have you know you get sand in your
coochie
you thought I was perfection girl it's
just a yeast infection really smell like
boo boo boo and I get yeast infection is
common ladies wear cotton pennies but
asking for it like this girl for sure
for sure white is back to front for
surfacer saying in your coochie that
sounds like a dope song seen any coochie
say
saying only coochie thing you could you
can sing and your coochie water in your
ears water in your water water in your
ears what we're seeing on your coochie
st.
swipe on our phones about how we're
doing it's so fast
you it's your thumb okay you can stay
because he fingers or slice it um you
know I really do love brown eyes like
I'm gonna start there
what's a brown hair black hair so they
have to have brown or black hair this
count is something I think so all right
we're about brown eyes and brown hair
and black hair counts right round eyes
black and I call the guys who had dark
hair just didn't come back directly no
no we don't want to go
Oh Ronald religion ooh yeah I prefer
somebody who
it's not religious yes just because your
whole scope is religion dum-dum a word
that you said before you King Kuber yeah
[Music]
you just say you're not into religious
people I don't know I don't know yet to
phrase it like a total jackass no she's
been phrasing or [ __ ] like I told Zack
yes I'm down for like you know when
we're like senior citizens to get be
like domestic partners but Oh I do want
a house to the backyard to grow some
strawberries that's all how'd you glad
you been with your girl for 21 years
yo this is what you do with no no I know
how to avoid these kind of brats
this was out there is it what's fighting
in your dm's man cut me give me a
[Music]
hallway
hey I guarantee you a lot of these guys
probably don't you want kids or they
don't care about it what they didn't
even want to make the effort to try and
hit it they just like please do keep me
away from this bra that's how to test
yes that's that he looks like the
unhappiest winner of all time
he's like yay me this was really weird
it was interesting
we're in 28 team it feels like we're
definitely like going places
mr. Cozzi be tough see see what that V
cancerous everything see koala ball yeah
I didn't speak a word in English most of
you didn't understand that's exactly how
I feel about what you just said
Kiska that V Davila daaaaisy the
wreckage earth rmz Sebastian Dajjal ty
Lindsey waste of time we're definitely
going play them no no no I just think
like I know what I want and if somebody
knows what they want why not say it to
manifest it you know like people have
set it straight to my face before and
like that feels right I don't know like
you're too young and it's like okay cool
I have no control over that or like you
smoke too much weed it's like well I
have control over that but [ __ ] you am I
gonna change so why waste time you know
here's what Damon has taught me over the
years
don't be so constricted in your view of
what your partner has to be like because
as you experience different things
you're going to understand why you like
the things that you like and you're
going to learn about things that you
didn't even know you liked I think also
one thing we have to acknowledge is that
the kind of women who would volunteer to
do this kind of show probably aren't the
brightest
your things wedgie it's better now but I
mean it's why what's work it's all of
that you have to go through all of them
now it's not that bad honestly dating
like you not only end up with women like
that if you don't filter them out how
the [ __ ] am i if ever like me my girl
not to get anymore knock on wood
I'm gonna be lost no ya know because you
know how to keep those kind of people
away from you it's not that different
mmm so I know how to avoid people I know
I don't want to talk to mmm because of
the fact that through dating and through
experiencing these different types of
people I've kind of seen different tales
does that make sense I'm saying right
like I've experienced it there for now I
know how to avoid it I don't I want to
watch this now you guys got to suffer
like we did tell us what you guys
thought about the video would you date
her please leave the circle now if you
would not date her and I just hope that
a whole bunch of people just leave
without wearing is like ah Jerry Jerry
what are you doing I can't date this
chick just leave it at any rate doesn't
you guys think peace seen any Lucy
laying on the beach yes I was perfection
girl
[Music]